thank you
such a great crowd we get now
okay here we are with our questions this
is for you catherine you recently went
on a tour of an irs office in texas is
that true yes
all right next question no uh
what was the most surprising oh texas
look what a connection you just did a
movie about texas you went on a tour
[Laughter]
what was the most surprising thing you
saw do you think the inflation reduction
acts investments in the irs will remedy
well first of all why did you go on a
tour of the irs because i had heard for
years fun day
it was it was wild i am telling you it
was wild it was like going on the
weirdest willy wonka tour
because like this place is usually
locked down everybody knows about the
irs obviously but they don't let people
in there
and they don't like them in texas
uh no they don't there was a lot of
security
so i had heard all these stories about
how old their software is and i had been
hearing these these anecdotes about how
crazy it was like
you know that they don't
scan in your tax return they have
someone manually type in number by
number into their computers the numbers
from your tax return if you file by
paper
into the system which is like
mind-blowingly stupid
and then they have people who
have to renumber with a red pen every
line on your tax return if you filed
last year's instead of this year's
because the computer system is again
it's it's literally from the 1970s it's
so old it can't like process more than
one return at a time so this is why
there are 10 million tax returns that
are in a backlog people can't get their
refunds this bill that biden signed this
week
has 80 billion dollars because that's
why right that's what that's for right
well about 80 billion dollars to the irs
yeah of course the republicans are
saying you're going to use this money to
blah blah blah blah blah but to audit
middle class
well
some of it will because well it's being
used to replenish their enforcement
capacity yes which has been completely
depleted over the past 10 years and and
who is benefiting from that it is
corporations and they're very rich
we'll be buying new computers for the
kids okay well not for the kids but for
the people who were like manually
stamping stuff and typing things in some
of that yeah but 80 billion dollars
doesn't right isn't covering the cost of
software alone it's mostly child labor
at the ira
no it's that's one person is like a 60
year old woman okay um yeah bj do you
think hollywood is partially responsible
for promoting rural stereotypes and the
conception of a disparate america
rural
stereotypes thoughts well look hollywood
perpetuates every
good and bad thing and exaggerates it
and
makes it also more subtle and beautiful
hollywood does everything
so i don't know well
then i would say this when i was a kid
there was these shows called the green
jean shows
some of them were taped right in this
building
because this is cbs i'm talking about
the beverly hillbillies
applaud if you remember these
green anchors
[Applause]
[Music]
teddy goat junction
andy griffith show
and then spin-offs from that remember mr
drucker
my point i don't know what my point is
except cbs lived on
shows about rural america
in the 60s and 70s that was like their
bread and butter and that's where i as a
kid in new jersey
got all my knowledge of the southern
part of the country was the beverly
hillbillies and mr drucker a documentary
clearly yeah i mean that was it so i
mean i live in western new jersey now
it's it's pretty rural it still feels a
lot like the beverly hillbillies
western new jersey pennsylvania really
yeah you get really in touch with your
roots there is a yeah people you know
i know i mean wasn't it james carver who
said pennsylvania is pittsburgh and
philadelphia with alabama in the middle
a lot of america is likely sure in the
northeast
uh
now as an anti-trump conservative could
you get yourself to vote for a democrat
if it meant keeping trump out of office
i can't imagine that new jersey would
ever be that competitive um
but if that's the hypothetical scenario
that it has there's a it's a razor tight
race and you have to vote for the
democrat
um that's not trump
i really don't know what i'd do i might
but it would be the first democrat i've
ever voted for democrats don't represent
my values they don't advance policies i
support so i don't support them i also
don't have to vote for the republican if
i don't support the republican there's
such a thing as just writing in mitt
romney which i've done several cycles
now
and we'll probably continue to do but uh
isn't that just a cowardly dodge maybe
maybe but it's also trump is a special
category of someone who doesn't believe
in our system
so no matter what the dem you really
think joe biden or hillary clinton or
any of them i know they don't your
values blah blah blah hillary clinton no
i don't think that isn't their number
one value america and what it is that
the democrats
democracy and america are inextricably
linked that's what the democrats still
believe but the republicans don't
believe that anymore i share the
assumption on your part that i think is
at the root of this question that the
foundations of democracy would be
under threat in the event that trump
somehow managed to win a second election
if that was my gun pointed to my head if
that was the situation then yeah i would
vote against that wow that situation is
highly unlikely to unfold
trump running again no that the notion
here that he's that it'll come down to
my vote but if it did i most certainly
would vote against donald trump
all right i prosecuted you as much as i
can i
i feel like i will leave it to the jury
at this point
our final question japanese officials
worried about shifting demographics in a
decline in tax revenue are now
encouraging young people to drink more
should we be doing something similar
given your belief oh this is you again
but i guess we can all
that young people aren't having any fun
anymore well
trust me they're still having fun i mean
when you're young it's hard to avoid it
but uh i read that too japanese
officials are encouraging drinking well
i i don't know yeah and the
overconsumption of alcohol can sometimes
be fun but not always and i don't
necessarily think that the two are
directly well they didn't say over
consumption
it is uh it's a social lubricant
precisely sometimes a lubricant
lubricant
no i don't know what that means
it is bj you are on the office what do
you think i think it's sort of like your
dad coming down to the basement with a
six-pack it's just it's suspicious you
don't want the government
telling you they're so right encouraging
you to train right it does it takes all
the fun out of it i don't know why it's
the government's job to decide the
optimal amount of drinking
you know if it's just like a weird i
think what it is is the the japanese
government is worried about population i
talked about this a few weeks ago i
don't understand this world that's
worried about less population we need
less population they're all worried
about population is declining i'm
throwing a party population japan has
like
who japan has serious demographic
challenges
democracy the world has the biggest
they're all really old there's like no
one they're not all old they have a very
high share of old people in japan
engaged people
pay the taxes to support the old people
the population bomb theory is kind of
bunk it's really never been supported
and it's justified just about every
eugenicist abuse of the human species
since 1968. okay so you're saying we can
just continue to have more people on
earth which has limited resources just
this was the theory in 1968 and we've
subsequently invented ourselves out of
the problems associated with
overpopulation we've created we also
have a crisis creating new methods of
feeding and transmitting goods across
the planet and every person is an
economic unit has contributed to that
but the like
our
river here that supplies the water to
the west the colorado river
it's got 28 left in the reservoirs we're
all the states around here are going to
have to stop using water it's going to
be mandated
i'm okay with that i don't need a lawn
but
water
people i mean these are just basic facts
i don't know i don't get this
argument that we just keep having more
people because
it's a it's a economic problem well
it's a water problem it's more basic
than economics well it's a resource
problem israel faced a very similar
problem
and desalination desalination was the
answer and that's an engineering problem
and that
is not necessarily a
problem of too many people more the more
people who contribute to that solution
so you're talking better from the ocean
precisely yeah good because those waters
are rising and we will need to be doing
something with it let's drink it
once again we solve everything here on
real time thank you ladies and gentlemen
thank you
you